RETO MEIER: Hi.
My name is Reto Meier, and I'm
the tech lead for Google's
Android Developer
Relations team.
This Efficient Data Transfers
DevByte focuses on how you can
use prefetching to implement
the big cookie model of
efficient data transfers and
improve your app's user
experience by reducing latency
and improving battery life.
In previous Efficient Data
Transfers DevBytes, I looked
at the cell radio state machine
and examined ways to
analyze apps' data transfer
profiles to uncover
anti-patterns, such as these
short, intermittent peaks and
consecutive but non-overlapping
downloads.
Having discovered potential
problems in this episode, I'll
look at how to use prefetching
to solve some of them.
We know that carriers adjust
the timings of cell radio
state machine to compromise
between data transfer latency
and battery drain.
Within our app, we want to
create the perfect user
experience that actually sits
here, at the sweet spot of
nonexistent latency and
virtually no battery impact.
Is such a thing even possible?
Yes, it is.
Prefetching offers the best of
both worlds, an effective way
to reduce battery trained by
reducing the number of data
transfers and minimizing the
in-app latency triggered when
users have to wait for downloads
to complete before
performing an action
or viewing data.
By downloading all of the data
that they're likely to need
for the current session in a
single burst, over a single
connection at full capacity, you
can significantly reduce
the number of radio
activations.
Your challenge is figuring out
what you need to download
ahead of time so that you can
present the user with exactly
what they need, when they need
it, without simply downloading
everything and wasting battery
power and bandwidth,
downloading data that's
never used.
How aggressively you prefetch
depends on the size of the
data being downloaded and the
likelihood of it being used.
As a rough guide for a typical
cell radio connected over 3G,
you can prefetch around
six seconds.
That's about one to two megs
worth of data, if that data
has a 50% chance of being used
within the current session.
Now at that point, the likely
cost of downloading any unused
data matches the substantial
savings lost by not
downloading that data
to begin with.
But of course, not every
network transfers
data at the same rate.
So the equation will change
based on the speed of
transfers and the efficiency of
the cell radio technology.
This code sets a default value
for 3G networks and increases
or decreases the size of the
prefetch cache based on the
speed and cost of
each network.
Note that we want to prefetch
significantly more data on
faster 4G networks.
And that's both to account for
the larger amount of data that
can be downloaded within the
same time period, but also
because of the higher
battery cost
associated with these radios.
So that makes it even more
important that we avoid extra
straight transitions
whenever we can.
But if networks are different,
so are our apps.
And as the likelihood of the
data being used increases, so
does the amount of data it's
worth prefetching.
So it's important to understand
both what data your
users are likely to use and
what your app's average
session length is.
A good starting point is to
expect session lengths of
around two to five minutes.
So large downloads, such as
video files, should be
downloaded in chunks at
regular intervals.
Using the same logic for a music
player, it would be good
practice to maintain a buffer
of one song, in addition to
the one already being played,
rather than prefetching, say,
a whole album or playlist.
This mitigates the risk of
wasting significant bandwidth
and battery life if your user
stops listening halfway
through a song.
You can take a similar approach
when streaming by
using HTTP live streaming,
which transmits audio in
bursts, rather than maintaining
a continuous
stream that will keep the
radio constantly active.
If we look at something like a
news app, things get a little
more complicated.
A typical use case for a music
player is to find an album or
playlist, hit play,
and then listen.
So you have a really good
chance of knowing what's
coming next and a reasonable
expectation for what your user
is going to do.
And they're going to have a
reasonable expectation that
there's going to be a start-up
latency if they
select a new track.
Now in contrast, the browsing
path when you're using
something like a news reader is
much less predictable, with
readers potentially swiping
between dozens of different
categories and jumping between
hundreds of articles.
In many ways, a news reader
behaves a lot like a browser,
so your approach to prefetching
can utilize some
of the same techniques browsers
use to improve speeds.
Now, the most naive solution is
to download the headlines
for a category once it's been
selected and download the
related thumbnails when they
scroll into view, and then
each of the articles once
it's been clicked.
Now this forces the radio to
remain active for basically
the entire session as you're
switching categories,
scrolling headlines, and reading
different articles.
And as a bonus, each click is
going to have that latency
associated with it, as it has
to download and process and
present the data that
you've selected.
A much better approach is
prefetching a reasonable
amount of data at start-up and
prioritizing the first set of
news headlines and thumbnails
which are likely to be
displayed, and continuing on
with the remaining headlines
and thumbnails and also,
article text.
Now it's also important to
ensure that your prefetching
doesn't delay the app start-up
by making the app wait for the
prefetch to complete
fully before
letting the user interact.
The worst example of this is
apps that display a splash
screen until a ping
or download or
process cycle is completed.
So be sure to process all
of your downloads in the
background, using IntentServices
and libraries
like Volley to help process that
data progressively and
concurrently and therefore
minimize
that start-up latency.
The real trick is being able
to accurately guess which
articles each user is
likely to read and
prefetch only those.
Now one approach is a
breadth-first search, assuming
that users are more likely
to read articles
via the current one.
Or you can go depth-first and
bank on them reading lots of
articles on a given topic.
Now a better approach
is to use science.
Measure how your content is
actually being consumed, and
use that to inform your
decisions dynamically and on a
per-user basis.
You can start by keeping track
of the metadata associated
with the content read by each
user, such as the categories
or authors.
You can widen the scope further
by incorporating the
content that their friends use
by integrating a social graph
like Google+.
And finally, you can aggregate
all of this information
together across all of your
users and discover what's
being used by a lot of people.
Now taken together, you can form
a sophisticated picture
of typical and expected usage
patterns of your app,
customized for each user.
And that allows you to make an
intelligent choice over which
data you should prefetch.
If that all sounds like a bit
too much work, then for some
apps, it may even make sense to
simply prefetch everything,
effectively providing support
for a fully offline
experience.
This can be really effective
for apps with data that
doesn't change very often,
such as magazines.
But you risk spending
significant bandwidth and
battery life downloading content
that's never used, so
it should be done
with caution.
One way to mitigate that cost
associated with downloading
more than five minutes worth
of data is to schedule the
download to occur at a time
when bandwidth and battery
life isn't important,
specifically when the device
is charging and connected to
Wi-Fi, as determined here by
using the Connectivity Manager
and Battery Manager.
And as long as you're monitoring
the device state,
why not take it a step further
and track the current activity
of the user?
Using the new location-based
services Activity Recognition
API, you can modify the
aggressiveness of your
prefetching based on what
the user is doing.
In this example, we're going to
increase the amount that we
prefetch when the user has the
app open and standing still,
the assumption being that
they're more likely to be
browsing articles while
stationary than if they're
riding a bike.
Now so far, we've talked about
the case where the app is
active in the foreground, but
it's worth considering the
background case too.
Should we prefetch data when the
app is in the background?
Well, generally speaking, it's
better practice to delay your
downloads until the app is
open, though this will
increase your start-up
latency.
A good approach is to use Google
Cloud Messaging to
notify your app of updates
available on the server.
That eliminates the need to
poll, to check for updates,
and provides a channel to notify
your app of exactly
what it should be requesting
at start-up.
Typically, you'll use GCM as a
way to initiate client-side
notifications without
the app needing to
initiate a separate download.
But where it makes sense, you
can use this same mechanism to
trigger background updates.
I'll cover GCM in more detail,
as well as topics including
batching, bundling transfers,
and using SyncAdapters, in
future episodes of the Efficient
Data Transfers
DevBytes series.